franki grande speaks out on the
terrorist attack at his little sister
Ariana Grande's concerts in Manchester
England almost a week to the day after
the tragic bombing that left 22 people
dead and 59 injured the 34 year old
reality star took to Twitter to share
his condolences tweeting my prayers
thoughts meditations and strength has
been focused on those families and
victims affected by the horrific tragedy
we can't allow hate to propagate hate
and fear to propagate fear but rather
come together and spread a message of
love unity and empowerment according to
TMZ Ariana will be heading back to
Manchester much sooner than anticipated
and is planning to headline a
star-studded benefit concert in the
victims honors just two weeks after the
deadly attack ariana is said to be
reaching out to some of the biggest
names in music to participate and the
concert will be held at one of the four
big arenas in the city all the proceeds
will go to the victims and their
families